foreign
with the fat community over at Tick Tock
a realm that we may call thick talk
that's actually my producer Sean's joke
now as the host of the show it's my
god-given right to steal the joke
without credit I can steal any joke I
hear around here because it's mine
that's the way it goes but I've decided
to forego that privilege and give credit
where it's due in this case so there it
is Tick Tock anyway we'll start with one
recent viral video from a fat activist
and then perhaps we'll continue down the
thick talk rabbit hole and see what else
we may find here it is
I'm gonna prove to you why white people
are the reason I'm fat today
if white people didn't go looking for
spices then a various sea routes to
Indian subcontinent and Africa and other
places of the world would not get
discovered
and if they didn't get discovered then
East India Company would never come to
Indian subcontinent
and if they didn't come then the
fertility of the land would not get
destroyed because they forced us to
cultivate tobacco and dyes and opioid
things like that and that destroyed the
fertility of my country
and then if that didn't happen and if
they didn't exploit and extract
resources until my ancestors were left
with nothing to eat we wouldn't move to
this grain heavy very little nutritious
diet that we have today
also if white people didn't come to the
Indian subcontinent then my ancestors
would not go through 50
small medium large famines in a period
of 200 years
that's a lot
and in 1943 nearly 3 million people
would not have died due to starvation
and malnutrition
and if that didn't happen then this
entire place and the people of this
place would not
adapt to survive on Lower calories
okay I didn't realize I was a 45-minute
club uh but it's a fun game I have to
admit it's like it's like the
self-victimizing version of seven
degrees of Kevin Bacon just take some
negative aspect of yourself that you
don't want to take responsibility for
and then find a way to cast the blame as
far away from yourself as possible I can
do this too you know for instance I tend
to be impatient and at times
ill-tempered I admit it's not my fault
though it can actually be traced
directly back to Alexander the Great's
invasion of Persia in 334 BC
I'll need to do some research on
Wikipedia to connect all the dots but
I'm sure there's a way to do it actually
in This Woman's case you might compare
it more to a sort of um it's sort of
like a butterfly effect but for fatness
so a butterfly flaps its wings 700 miles
away sets off a chain of causation
that eventually ends with this girl
eating a cheeseburger although here in a
rather extraordinary feat of deflection
she has punted responsibility actually
out of this Century halfway across the
previous millennium
imagine that the mental gymnastics
required to be in the process of
devouring
like a Cinnabon while thinking to
yourself this is all Vasco de Gama's
fault damn you Vasco
meanwhile there is as always
an obvious contradiction at work here on
the one hand we're told that fat is
beautiful fat is good fat is healthy fat
is desirable
on the other hand it's also very
important for us to believe that fat
people are fat through no fault of their
own so it's like this is good
but it's not my fault
well if it's beautiful and good then why
would you not want to take credit for it
in fact if white people made this girl
fat then shouldn't she be thanking us
given that fat is beautiful We Made You
Beautiful you're welcome
which is it is my question you have to
choose pick a lane
either it's bad and it's not my fault
or it's good in which case the blame
game makes no sense
let's watch the next one
stop shaming and skinny shaming are the
same actually no they're not fat people
are denied jobs proper Medical Care
Health Insurance they're paid less they
don't have equal access to clothing
travel many public spaces even the body
mass index the way that it discriminates
against women especially women of color
it was created for and based around
white men like fat phobia is literally
rooted in anti-blackness it's rooted in
racism and sexism skinny shaming is not
how many times have you seen marketing
campaigns that are labeled get fat quick
finally add those stubborn 30 pounds
show me where all the weight gain
Industries are show me all the damaging
messages that say that skinny equals
unworthy life or skinny equals ugly when
is the last time that you've been
penalized financially when an aircraft
seed had to be accommodated to your
smaller body when is the last time
you've walked into a doctor's office and
after they weighed you stop listening to
what you were actually there for and
told you to just gain weight because it
will fix everything fat people endure
all of that and more skinny people do
not face employment discrimination or
medical discrimination the world was
designed for you eat a burger is just
not comparable to systemic abuse and
oppression
I mean she's absolutely right you know
fat shaming and skinny shaming are not
the same because if you're shaming
somebody for being skinny then you're
shaming them for a healthy physique
provided that they aren't you know rail
thin
if you're shaving them for being fat
you're shaming them for being in an
unhealthy and destructive physical state
you really shouldn't be walking up to
people and shaming them for their
appearance in either case but it is
without question worse to shame a good
thing than it is to shame a bad thing
does it make sense that the same company
who controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on your private
conversations at home big Tech is more
powerful than most countries are and
they profit by exploiting your personal
data it's time to put a layer of
protection between your online activity
and big Tech and that's why I use
expressvpn think about how much of your
life is on the internet sadly every site
you visit video you watch messages said
gets tracked and data mined but when you
run expressvpn on your device the
software hides your IP address something
big Tech can use to personally identify
you so expressvpn makes your activity
harder to trace and harder to sell to
advertisers therefore expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your internet data to
keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers that are on your network
what I like most about expressvpn is how
easy it is to use you can download the
app on your phone or computer tap one
button and that's it you're protected
and expressvpn does all this without
showing or slowing down your connection
that's why it's rated the number one VPN
service by techradar The Verge and
countless others so stop handing all of
your personal data over to the big Tech
Monopoly who Minds your activity and
sells your information protect yourself
with the VPN that I trust to keep me
safe online visit expressvpn.com
walshyt to get to get three extra months
free
but my favorite part of this clip is is
her list of oppressions and persecutions
that fat people face she says fat people
don't have equal access to clothing
which is an interesting way of putting
it so if I Gorge myself during
Thanksgiving and put on five pounds in
one weekend I can then complain that I
don't have equal access to my own pants
anymore yet
contrary to the way she phrases it there
is no law preventing fat people from
wearing clothing I mean incidentally
this I was this is actually news that
someone should probably share with lizzo
like you know you can you're allowed to
wear clothes just so you know
by the way the reason
there aren't advertisements telling
people how to add pounds she says why
are there any average there's no ads
tell people to put on pounds
well the reason for that is that number
one you don't want to add pounds right
it's unhealthy but also nobody needs
help doing that
putting on weight is easy and fun and
often delicious you just make a tray of
brownies that's all it takes
there's no further assistance required
so that's why you don't find that
let's check out one more
I'm gonna be real with y'all I am really
sick and tired of skinny it's coming on
this app and trying to compare fat
phobia to getting called the door once
that's called body shaming and it
literally happens to every single person
on the planet at least once it's not a
systemic issue girl I went to my doctor
when I got diagnosed with severe
depression and she dead ass looked at me
and said lose some weight and break up
with your boyfriend I was in school
today thinking about where I wanted to
go for off-campus lunch and I started
looking up restaurant menus and realized
that I didn't want to linger on the tab
too long in case somebody looked over
the fat girl's laptop seeing where she
wanted to go for lunch and judging me
for it I can't walk into a 7-Eleven and
order a Slurpee and some Skittles
because I'm afraid that when I put them
down on the counter like a skinny person
could do with no problem somebody's
gonna judge me for it I've applied to a
job at a restaurant and heard somebody
say oh they're not gonna hire me because
they think I'm fat enough to eat all the
food I'm terrified to be seen eating in
my car or eating alone y'all got
insulted once and ran with it
this is what the Youth of today are
spending their energy on is this is what
they're arguing these are the subjects
they're discussing what's worse fat
shaming or skinny shaming oh my God
okay let's go through a few things here
I would absolutely absolutely judge you
if you were buying a Slurpee and
Skittles at the same time I mean fat or
skinny if I see someone washing down
Skittles with a Slurpee yes I'm gonna
make some judgments about that person
that's disgusting and you would deserve
to be judged for it absolutely you
deserve judgment in fact if someone
walked up to you to your face and made
fun of you for buying Slurpees and scale
at the same time you would deserve that
too it'd be good it'd be a wake-up call
for you it's like an intervention
guess what you don't get to be free of
the world's judgment here's the news
flash for everybody watching right now
you don't get to be free of the world's
judgment you don't nobody does you are
being judged all the time all the time
people look at us and observe our
behavior and make judgments that's
sometimes the judgments are bad
sometimes they're good sometimes they're
neutral this is just what it means to
live in a society among other rational
creatures you can accept that and move
on with your life or you can sit around
crying about I'm being judged stop being
judged yes you are okay we've
established that live your life now
or just stay huddled in the corner in a
fetal position stop judging me
well you've chosen the latter I suppose
and now you're on Tick Tock like I I
can't I can't even Freebase pixie sticks
behind the dumpster at 7-Eleven without
being judged of course you can
nor should such Behavior be free of
judgment
also you most certainly were not turned
down for a job at a restaurant because
the interviewer said you'd eat all the
food okay that that just didn't happen
it absolutely 100 did not happen
um however did a doctor actually tell
you that the cure for depression is to
break up with your loser boyfriend and
shed a few pounds I hope so because
that's actually fantastic advice I wish
more doctors would help their patients
adjust their Lifestyles before writing
prescriptions you had a good doctor who
cared about your health which is why I
assume you never went back to him again
all in all
if these experiences as you describe
them actually all happened and were
upsetting to you there is a solution
it's a solution totally within your
power you can lose weight it won't be
easy but you can do it it is possible I
know from experience that there is a
correlation between Diet lifestyle and
weight we all know this from experience
this is the point the fat activists the
fatavis seem to always miss you can't
lie to the rest of us about this issue
you can't pretend that you have nothing
to do with your own waistline
all of us have experienced putting on
weight because we ate too much and
didn't get enough exercise all of us in
the modern world have experienced that
we know that's how it works
we also know that it's difficult it
takes self-control to practice dietary
discipline
and we know that's why you don't want to
do it not because you're oppressed or
the victim of white supremacy it's just
it's hard and you don't want to do
something that's hard we've all been
there
to one degree or another
which is why you would actually have our
sympathy if you just said
I know I can get healthy but it's really
hard and so I'm struggling
you could just say that that's a
statement I totally sympathize with
because whether it's weight or something
else we all have things about ourselves
that we don't like or we want to improve
you know but but we have trouble
improving those things because it's hard
it's hard to improve something about
yourself doesn't matter what it is and
we all have flaws and so if your flaws
that you tend to over overeat and you
don't get enough exercise and so you put
on weight that's a flaw it is a flaw
you're not the only one in the world of
flaws we all have them now you could
rightly point out that we all have flaws
that's true
but when you make your flaw into a Cause
right into a a banner that you march
under and and you want to you try to
convince the world that your flaw is
actually a virtue
well now you've made it an issue we have
to talk about
and that's on you
if you would just admit that it's a flaw
that you do have control over it then
then it's a holy it's it's an entirely
different situation
you know and and all the for the rest of
us with our flaws we have them not
because uh and we have trouble solving
them not because we can't solve them or
it's impossible or because it's all the
fault of spice traders in the 1500s
we can control ourselves but it's
difficult and we have trouble doing
difficult things everyone does that's
why we call them difficult
that's something that we can all as
humans relate to and sympathize with and
we can commiserate with each other about
that
we can also support each other and help
each other
but you can't really have anyone's
support or anyone's help or even
sympathy if you refuse to be accountable
for your own choices
as long as you insist on blaming
everything and everyone but yourself
you'll never get over the hurdle you'll
be stuck with the burden forever while
trying to convince yourself that you're
happy with it but you know better you're
not
and that is why
these fat activists on Tick Tock are
today unfortunately I must say canceled
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really as that's what
it is we're enjoy we're forming a cult
then all you gotta do is click the
Subscribe button and ring the bell below
this video to stay up to date with all
my content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at the
daily wire.com Spotify or apple podcast
looking forward to welcoming you to the
Sweet Baby gang